So let's recap what we've talked about today. We started off today by
talking about one of the most important concepts in all of knowledge based AI,
which are knowledge based representations. As we go forward in this class,
we'll see knowledge representations are really at the heart of nearly everything
we'll do. We then talked about semantic networks, which are a good particular
kind of [UNKNOWN] representation and we used those to talk about the different
criteria for a good knowledge representation. What do good knowledge
representations enable us to do and what to they help us avoid? We then talked
about kind of an abstract class of problem solving methods called Represent and
Reason. Represent and reason really lies under all of knowledge based AI and
it's a way of representing knowledge and then reasoning over it.
We then talked a little bit about augmenting that with weight, which allows us
to come to more nuanced and specific conclusions. In the next couple weeks, we
are going to use these semantic networks to talk about a few different problem
solving methods. Next time, we'll talk about generating tests and
then we'll move on to a couple slightly different ones called Means and
Analysis and Proper Reduction.